this video is sponsored by the book
summary app blinkist click the link in
the description and receive one free
week and 25 off a full membership
known as the father of western
philosophy ancient greek philosopher
socrates is regarded as one of the most
influential thinkers in history
encouraging and shaping the early
budding of philosophy and directly
inspiring other formative ancient greek
philosophers like plato and aristotle
socrates would be a catalyst to the way
humanity has and continues to think
about the world and the way we live
within it
there are no known works directly
attributed to socrates so he remains a
fairly mysterious figure all accounts of
his life and philosophy are provided by
other classical writers many of which
differ and sometimes contradict each
other in historical studies this is what
is known as the socratic problem making
it difficult if not impossible to fully
pin down an accurate image of him
however most of what is understood and
believed to be closest to accurate is
found in the work of one of his students
named plato who would go on himself to
become an essential figure in socrates's
legacy as well as the development of
western philosophy in general writing
around 36 books all comprised of
dialogues primarily featuring socrates
it is generally agreed that socrates was
born in athens and ancient greece in
around 469 bc it is believed that his
philosophical occupation began after a
successful career as a sculptor and
serving with distinction in the athenian
military during the peloponnesian war
during this later philosophically
focused part of his life socrates spent
most of his time wandering around greece
asking lots of questions and challenging
lots of men who the public believed to
be wise he would soon become very
skeptical of the so-called wisdom of the
time finding that most men who claimed
and were held to be wise were
essentially just arrogant in plato's
book apology socrates says when
referring to a wise man
when i conversed with him i thought this
man seemed to be wise both to many
others and especially to himself but
that he was not and then i tried to show
him that he thought he was wise but was
not but of that he disliked me and so
did many others who were there but i
went away thinking to myself that i was
wiser than this man the fact is that
neither of us knows anything beautiful
and good but he thinks he does know when
he doesn't and i don't know and don't
think i do so i am wiser than he is only
by this trifle that what i do not know i
don't think i do
it was this that socrates belief
separated him from others of the time
and defined true wisdom and arguably he
was right as this credo would ultimately
become one of the defining components of
his legacy that has lasted millenniums
while most of the other wise men of the
time disappeared in mere generations at
best
socrates would go on to spend much of
his time attempting to teach and
convince others to question what they
held to be true and realize as he put it
the only true wisdom is knowing you know
nothing
in doing so he believed he would compel
others to join him on a journey of
philosophical inquiry toward a better
life as they realized their current
answers and beliefs were insufficient
as time would pass socrates would garner
a following of young students interested
in his way of thinking although he was
skeptical of knowledge and popular ideas
he was not without convictions he taught
and made claims about politics being
extremely critical of democracy made
assessments of values prioritizing
virtue self-knowledge goodness truth and
happiness over wealth fame and power
developed explanations of ethics
believing that evil is always done out
of ignorance and harms the doer more
than the victim defined concepts of the
soul and the list goes on
arguably most notably however is that
differing from the more cosmic focus of
the pre-socratic thinkers before him
socrates maintained that the purpose of
philosophy was answering the very
practical down-to-earth question what is
the way we ought to live
despite his good intentions though
socrates's efforts were often poorly
received by the public after pushing his
luck too far he was put on trial for
religious impiety and corrupting the
youth he was found guilty and sentenced
to death
in 399 bc he would be given a cup of
poison hemlock to drink which would
slowly move through his body until
reaching his heart and taking his last
breath one of history's greatest minds
shut down for asking too many questions
about a world that was not yet ready to
admit it was still at the starting line
although his mission would be cut short
it would be far from unsuccessful
one of socrates's greatest legacies was
his student plato who would successfully
take the hand off from him and
officially begin the relay race of
western philosophy
plato would follow in socrates's
footsteps of skepticism critical
questioning reasoning and the
prioritization of knowledge toward
achieving what was termed eudemonia or
fulfilled happy life
unlike socrates however plato wrote down
his work and crafted a more defined
philosophical system producing around 36
books during his lifetime and setting up
the first ever university called the
academy
in this rite plato is considered by many
to be the first ever true philosopher at
least in the western tradition
in his work plato would explore ideas
related to things like love friendship
beauty politics ethics and happiness
however arguably one of if not his most
prominent and influential philosophical
contribution was his thinking about
thinking itself
following in socrates's skepticism of
knowledge plato's next move was to
question how we can and do come to know
things at all
ultimately plato believed that knowledge
is possible and that there are fixed
objective truths to be discovered and
used
more accurately rediscovered as plato
believed all knowledge was innate prior
to birth and then forgotten upon birth
requiring recollection through reasoning
and what would become known as platonic
idealism plato would separate the realm
of truth from the material world
distinguishing the world of things as we
perceive them from the world of things
as they really are
for plato reality as we observe it is a
flawed reflection of a higher truth
around beyond time space and the human
mind containing universalities and
abstract objects that exist in their
purest unchanging ideal form
plato would refer to these as the forms
with the capital f and suggested that
they function as the fundamental
building blocks of the material world
as a simplified example consider how
there are many trees in the world but
that all trees are different there is no
tree that is the same as any other but
all trees are still trees
according to plato this is because all
trees are imperfect shadows of the
perfect ideal tree form that all trees
are made from through which we can
discern a tree's treeness
from a practical standpoint plato
suggested that through reason and
philosophy individuals and societies
could understand the ideals of things
like justice happiness friendship being
and goodness in order to strive toward
and attain them plato would illustrate
this theory with arguably his most
popular written work the allegory of the
cave which is contained in book seven of
his work the republic
in which he tells the story of a group
of prisoners who have been chained up
facing a wall inside a cave ever since
birth with no knowledge of the outside
world on the wall shadows of different
shapes are casted by people passing with
various objects in front of a fire
behind them the prisoners name and
classify the shadows believing that they
are seeing the true forms of things
however when suddenly one of the
prisoners is freed he exits the cave and
discovers the real world outside all the
actual forms and qualities of the
objects that were previously just
displayed as shadows to him this
prisoner after realizing what he has
become aware of returns to the cave to
tell the other prisoners however when he
does they think he has gone insane
brainwashed or corrupted by whatever is
outside they respond not only with
resistance but also violence hostile to
his attempt to challenge their current
beliefs and encourage new improved
knowledge of the truth
there are of course multiple ways of
interpreting this allegory but in the
context of hysteria forms plato creates
the distinction between the shadows and
the objects they are casted from to
parallel the forms and the material
world we experience where we are all
caved inside our senses restricted and
ignorant to the true forms of things
the escaped prisoner representing the
philosopher who through reason
righteously tries to communicate his
discoveries but is resisted or even
killed by the public
as interesting innovative and useful as
this allegory is there is at least one
obvious issue with it which is perhaps
mirrored in the problem of plato's
philosophy in almost all of western
philosophy as a whole
how does the prisoner who was freed know
that once outside he's not merely in
another sort of cave
how does he know that the objects in
their supposed true or pure form outside
the cave are not merely another sort of
crude shadow casted by another purest
source he is not yet aware of or perhaps
could never be aware of and if he were
to somehow reach or discover a
subsequent truer realm how would he know
this one to be true does not the
increasing discovery of obviously true
things to be untrue increase the odds
that what is currently being discovered
is also untrue
of course although socrates and plato
were fundamental to the founding of
western philosophy both combining to
influence essential ideas and questions
about reality knowledge reason and the
way an individual and society ought to
exist much of what they believed and
claimed does not hold up today
although perhaps they were the escaped
prisoners of their time they were
nonetheless still prisoners to another
cave just outside of it
perhaps all reality is a prison and time
is its guard
in plato's apology socrates says to the
citizens of athens following his trial
i prophecy to you that after my death
the punishment will soon descend upon
you a punishment far more severe than
that which you have inflicted on me you
will have caused my death hoping in vain
to escape from my critical questioning
around 2 400 years later it would seem
that socrates's prophecy in at least
some sense has come true
we have yet to escape from his critical
questioning
with each new generation each new
philosophy and each new realm of
knowledge we find ourselves in the wake
of socrates still either unsure or in
denial
socrates plato and soon to be plato
student aristotle seemingly gave us some
of the first tools needed to begin
taking the whole world apart but they
never had and we likely never will have
an instruction manual to put it back
together
we still know very little of what it
means to be a self let alone a true self
what it means to live or how we ought to
what consciousness is why there is life
or a universe at all what the ultimate
purpose of literally anything and
everything is if there is any truth and
how we can know for sure and the list
goes on
one of the only true constants that
appears to have remained from the early
groundwork of ancient greek philosophy
is perhaps the recognition of our
ignorance the socratic paradox i know
that i know nothing
socrates knew he knew nothing but seemed
to believe that this paradox could be
overcome to good end
perhaps it can certainly in many
practical cases it seems to be but in
other cases of these bigger questions of
existence perhaps philosophy is in some
sense futile
perhaps there are no ultimate answers in
philosophy perhaps there never will be
but there are no ultimate answers in
music in art in a beautiful landscape or
in a conversation with a friend and yet
i know of no one who does not find value
insight love and solace and all of these
things perhaps by means of the very same
thing that cursed humanity with the need
to philosophize we can learn through
philosophy to enjoy philosophy's
futility
perhaps the purpose of philosophy then
at least of a certain broader kind is
best recontextualized in which the
ambiguity and unknowingness is an end in
it of itself rather than a means
perhaps what we should and only can do
is try to enjoy the process of playing
with the blocks of philosophy like
children playing with toy blocks for no
reason other than the curiosity and fun
of it not because in the end the blocks
will provide something that stays up
forever but because we inevitably will
take the blocks down put them away for a
little while and then play with them
again another day in a different way
and for that whether we agree or
disagree with socrates plato aristotle
or the western philosophical tradition
in general we can and should thank them
for this for providing the materials and
tools of thinking and questioning that
have and will continue to help provide
millennium's worth of philosophical
wonder
this video was sponsored by blinkist
whether you enjoy learning about higher
level philosophical thinking or just
want to learn more practical ideas
related to areas like your health or
career there is certainly no shortage of
literature and no shortage of reasons to
engage in it blinkus is a book summary
app that can help you do this more
easily and efficiently by allowing you
to discover and rediscover ideas from
entire nonfiction books and podcasts in
as little as 15 minutes taking over 5000
of the best nonfiction books in 27
categories and transforming them into
text and audio summaries that can be
read and listened to even while offline
blinkist allows you to easily transform
pockets of time into opportunities rife
with new knowledge and insights about
the world with the average best-selling
non-fiction book taking the average
reader about 10 and a half hours
blinkist essentially converts one book's
average time into around 42 books or
reduces the time it takes to learn from
one book by a multiple of 42 providing
you more time and space to learn from
more subjects and authors you might
never otherwise if you're interested in
learning more about the history and
progression of western philosophy
blinkist has the story of philosophy by
will durant which can help you ponder
and learn about the more human side of
some of history's greatest thinkers
allowing you to get inside their minds
and mindsets consider the world from
different lenses of history and be
inspired to perhaps try to do the same
as them if you're interested click the
link in the description and receive one
free week of unlimited access as well as
25 off of full membership the free
seven-day trial can be canceled at any
time within the trial period and of
course as always thank you so much for
watching in general and see you next
video
[Music]
you